hay mucho en juego tanto para anthony
blinken como para serguéi lávrov ambos
están en ginebra para encontrar una
salida diplomática a la crisis que ha
provocado un aumento de las tensiones
entre rusia y los líderes occidentales
moscú envió miles de soldados a su
frontera con ucrania vladímir putin
condicionó la retirada de las tropas
sólo si se garantiza que ucrania nunca
se unirá a la otan pero él niega haber
planeado una invasión un movimiento que
yo bailé dice que sería un desastre
que no quede ninguna duda de que si
putin toma esta decisión rusia pagará un
alto precio tampoco es el último
escenario para el que debemos estar
preparados rusia tiene una larga
historia del uso de medidas distintas a
la acción militar abierta para llevar a
cabo la agresión
la llegada de tropas rusas a belarús
sólo aumenta las tensiones
moscú también anunció operaciones
navales a gran escala en movimientos que
recuerdan a la guerra fría por su parte
eeuu busca formar un frente unido con
sus aliados occidentales una postura que
según muchos observadores pone a ambas
partes en un callejón sin salida ay feel
the turn me temo que mañana puede ser
ese día
donde se le labró y dice que no ve la
necesidad de seguir hablando
ok
entonces me imagino que una invasión
sería bastante inminente frank en medio
del estancamiento de la diplomacia
washington aprobó el envío de 200
millones de dólares en ayuda militar a
ucrania eeuu también autorizó a los
estados bálticos enviar armamento de
fabricación estadounidense a kiev para
ayudar a reforzar sus defensas